(intense rock music)
(audience applauding and cheering)
(audience laughing and cheering)
Suicide Squad, let's get 'em out here!
(audience applauding and cheering)
(upbeat rock music)
Hey, so he's young, right?
Okay, I want to do the Kessel Run in 16 parsecs, Mom.
(audience laughs)
Can we try that--
No notes, no notes!
(audience laughs)
Name?
Hey, Will Arnett.
(audience laughing and cheering)
I'm Han Solo.
(audience laughs)
How do you say it?
Han.
Han Solo.
(audience laughs)
Oh, hey, Han Solo.
You know, just like he's on his
way to do errands or whatever.
I'm also Batman.
(audience laughing and cheering)
(dramatic orchestral music)
(audience cheering and applauding)
(sentimental orchestral music)
(audience laughs)
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
(dramatic orchestral music)
We have a great show tonight!